l'urgence le chaos sont évidents
anti-âge ici ce qui ne sait pas déjà
affalé menace de le faire à tout instant
comme cet hôpital qui s'est dissocié
[Musique]
dit-il quand on a commencé les premières
opérations ça s'est écrasé de 1 m 20
dans le sol deux immeubles se sont
effondrés en centre choquant on essaie
d'atteindre les enfants
mais depuis le matin ce ne sont que des
corps qu'ils extirpent des gravats c'est
que les secours déployés en masse
aujourd'hui sont arrivés trop tard dit
ce jeune homme il est venu d'Istanbul
comme volontaire
ils ont abandonné à taille d'ici à
taille a disparu de la carte à la place
c'est un grand vide des corps dans des
sacs
il en manque pour les corps on les
transporte dans des couvertures c'est
une tâche sordide et épuisante
mais c'est pour des moments comme
celui-ci quelle est secouristes tiennent
le coup sucré 12 ans a survécu pendant
plus de 75 heures sous les décombres
quelques heures plus tard c'est Mia une
femme de 74 ans a été retrouvé vivante
son frère Mermet 69 ans la suivi de peu
c'est bien une catastrophe naturelle qui
a frappé la Turquie mais l'ampleur de
cette catastrophe elle ce sont les êtres
humains qui en sont responsables du
temps ici
en colère dit-il la construction n'est
pas bonne tout ça pour faire de l'argent
ils achètent des matériaux à peu de
frais c'est pour ça que tout est arrivé
il n'y a aucun contrôle
Gull se rappelle avec amertume ce que
l'on enseigne aux enfants pour qu'il
soit préparés en cas de séisme
pourquoi devrions-nous éduquer nos
enfants de mon tél c'est à vous de ne
pas donner de permis de construire que
voulez-vous que les enfants fassent ils
ont appris à préparer un sac en cas de
séisme avec un sifflet une lampe de
poche ils ont tout appris mais si on ne
donnait pas de permis de construire on
ne se retrouverait pas dans cette
situation
elle espère sans trop y croire qu'on
fera mieux maintenant qu'il faut tout
reconstruire
ici marie-eveda Radio-Canada Antioche